dr. vector will see you now we're at a
ripper doc clinic Ripper Doc's are
specialist vendors who offer people the
possibility to install or upgrade their
cyber need to bump up my specs and get a
grip
really now finally next [ __ ] just got
real
hit in the major leagues got a job from
Dexter Shawn the Dexter to shop yeah
that is something but let me guess
hasn't paid you yet quick Ryan Vick I'll
bring you the Eddy's later with interest
you know I will last time I swear now
sit
that's Karoshi best I've got and should
be about right under the circumstances
not Jackie
you perusing shoes while I scan see
what's going on inside we're going to
install both an optical scanner mark one
like I said decent enough scanner
displays data on your cornea and a
subdermal weapon ribbon links not
labeled and to be perfectly honest not
entirely sure where the hell I got it
still looks like it'll talk to Karoshi
tech huh I'm ready carve away okay I'll
clean now for the fun stuff they made
you League on yours right here just like
that
Thanks now a bit of an aesthetic and I
can start reading feel anything
duck way by play makes you sound like a
dentist you're always going on and on
don't be me now remember I'm old I got a
shaky Ganic hand could slip lights out
for a minute alright good so let's test
it
linking you in you might feel a little
discomfort
maybe blurred vision low contrast
glitches so how's it look to you with
the scanner we can zoom in on things and
take a closer look
this is fantastic beautiful time for the
scanner additionally we can analyze
objects get details on enemy weak points
or gang affiliation scanner should
eventually sink you to your thought
processes read your intentions Auto work
like a charm now draw your weapon you
should see your ammo count and a brand
new site the subdermal weapon links to
our skin and shows us weapon information
like ammo count and fire levels it also
increases the base damage on all
connected weapons vector not bad I don't
know what to say say you'll take this
and remember the dosage two whips now
and another two in an hour
thanks again you're the best Vic you're
on kids yawn what you can do
and once you hit the big-time don't
forget where you came from
while some Ripper docks operate legally
others provide black-market services for
the right price they can even offer to
install illegal military-grade cyberware